how the machine of the economy works
in 30 minutes the economy works like
a simple machine however many do
not understand or agree on how it
works and that has led to a lot of
economic and human suffering i
feel a deep obligation to
share my economic template
simple but  practical
yet unconventional helped me
predict and dodge the global financial
crisis and serves me well over
30 years ago let's start
though the economy may seem
complex it works simply and
mechanically it consists of a few
simple parts and many simple transactions
that take place  repeated over and over
countless times these transactions
are driven mostly by
human nature and create three
main forces that move the economy
an increase in productivity 2 the
cycle of short-term debt 3 the cycle
of long-term debt we will see these
three forces and how by superimposing
one on top of the other
we create a good template for  follow
economic movements and understand
what is happening
let's start with the simplest part of the
economy transactions
an economy is simply the sum of
the transactions that make it up and a
transaction is something very simple all the
time we make transactions every time
we buy something we create a
transaction
each transaction consists of a
buyer exchanging money or credit to
a seller for goods services or
financial assets
credit is spent like money
so adding money spent to
credit spent we know total
spending total spending drives the economy
if we divide  the amount spent times the
quantity sold we get the price and
that's it if this is a transaction it
's the backbone of the economy machine
the cycles and forces of an economy are
driven by transactions so if
we understand transactions
we understand the whole economy
a  market consists of all
buyers and all sellers  that
carry out transactions with the same thing for
example there is a wheat
market a car market a stock market
and markets for millions of things an
economy consists of all the
transactions in all its markets
if we add the total expenses and the
total quantity sold in  all
markets have everything we need to
know to understand the economy it's that
simple people businesses banks and governments
all engage in transactions as I
described above they exchange money and
credit for goods services and
financial assets the largest buyer and
seller is the government made up of
two important parties a
central government that has taxed and
spends money and a central bank that is
different from other buyers and
sellers because it controls the amount
of money and credit in the economy
it does so by influencing interest rates
and printing new money
for these reasons, as we will see, the
central bank is an impor  important in the
flow of credit
now let's pay attention to credit
credit is the most important part of the
economy and probably the least
understood it is the most important part
because it is the largest and the most volatile
just as buyers and sellers go to the
market to make transactions
also lenders and
borrowers lenders tend
to convert their money is more money
and borrowers often want to buy
something they can't afford like a house or
a car or want to invest in something like
starting a business credit can
help both lenders  as
borrowers to get what they want the
borrowers promise to repay the amount
borrowed called the principal plus an
additional amount called interest when
interest rates are high
fewer loans are taken because they are expensive when
interest rates are low
more loans are taken because  are cheaper
when borrowers promise to
repay the loan and lenders
believe them credit is created
any two people can agree to
create credit out of thin air this seems
pretty simple but credit is
elusive because it has
different names once credit
is generated it immediately becomes
debt debt is an asset for the lender
and  a liability for the borrower in the
future when the borrower repays the
loan with interest assets and liabilities will
disappear and the transaction is
settled
so why is credit so
important because when a borrower
gets credit it can increase their
spending and you have to remember spending
drives  the economy that's because
one person's spending is another person's income
let's think that every dollar we
spend is earned by someone and every dollar
we earn was spent by someone
so when we spend more someone earns
more when someone's income
increases  lenders are more
willing to lend you money because you are
now more creditworthy  a
credit worthy borrower has two
things the ability to repay the
loan and one they are going to have a
high income compared to the debt it allows
them to repay
money if they cannot do so they have
valuable assets as collateral that can be
sold
this makes lenders feel
comfortable lending money to themselves higher
incomes allow them to take more loans
which in turn allow higher expenses and
since one person's expenses are
another's income this leads to more
loans and so on this
behavior feeds back and leads to
economic growth and therefore  that we have
cycles
in a transaction you have to give something to
get something and when we get it depends
on how much we produce over time
we learn and that
accumulated knowledge living standards rise
we call this growth in
productivity those who are creative and
work hard increase their  productivity
and living standards faster
than those complacent  and lazy,
although not necessarily in the short term,
productivity counts more in the long
term, short-term credit, this is
because
productivity growth does not fluctuate much, so
it is not an important driver of
economic fluctuations, debt is,
because when you acquire it  allows us to
consume more than we produce and
forces us to consume less than
we produce when we repay it,
the fluctuations of the debt follow two
great cycles, one of between five to eight
years and the other of approximately 75 to 100 years,
although the majority  of
people feel the swings usually
don't see them as cycles because they see them
too closely day to day week to
week
in this chapter we'll take a step back
to look at these three big forces and
how they interact to create our
experiences
we saw that the swings around  the
line does not arise from how much innovation or
hard work there is but above all from
how much credit there is
let's imagine for a moment  an economy
without credit
in this economy I can only increase my
expenses if I increase my income which
requires me to be more productive and work
more higher productivity is the only
path to growth as my
expenses are someone else's income
the economy grows every time  that me or
anyone else is more productive if we follow
the transactions and show them we see
a progression as
the productivity growth line but
since we take loans we have cycles
this does not arise from any law or
regulation but from human nature
and how the system works  credit
let's think of taking loans as
stretching expenses forward to buy
something we can't afford we have to
spend more than we earn to do so
we must borrow from our own
future so we create a time in the
future when we will have to spend less
than  what we earn to be able to pay it back
very quickly resembles a cycle in
essence each loan that t  omos creates
a cycle this is as true for an
individual as it is for the economy
that is why it is so important to understand
credit because it sets in motion a series
of mechanical and predictable future events
this differentiates credit
from money money is what we
jump transactions with when  we buy
a beer with cash the transaction
is that it is settled immediately, on the other
hand if we buy it with credit it is
like opening an account at the bar
we promise to pay in the future
and together with the barman we create an asset and a
liability
we have just created credit out of nothing
only later when paying the bar bill does it
disappear into assets and liabilities
the debt vanishes and the transaction is
actually settled what most people call
money is in fact
credit total credit in the us
is about 50 million million  of
dollars and the total money in circulation
is barely 3 million million.
Let us remember that in an economy without credit,
the only way to  spending more is producing
more but in an economy with credit
we can also spend more by
borrowing as a result in an economy
with credit spending is higher
allowing income to rise
faster than productivity in the short
term but not in the long term now well
I don't  misunderstand credit is not
necessarily a bad thing that only causes
centuries it is bad when it finances an excess
of consumption that cannot be repaid,
however it is good when allocating
resources efficiently and producing income
that allows us to repay the debt for
example if we take a loan for
buy a large television that the
device does not generate income so that
we pay back what we borrowed but if we take
a loan to buy a tractor and
thus be able to harvest larger crops and
earn more money
we can pay back what we borrowed and improve
our standard of living in an economy
with credit we can  follow
transactions and see how credit
generates growth let's see an example
Let's imagine that we earn one hundred thousand dollars a
year and we have no debt,
so if they lend us ten thousand dollars,
let's suppose that
we could spend 110 thousand dollars on a credit card, although
in reality we only earn 100 thousand, since
my expenses are someone else's income,
someone is earning 110  thousand dollars the
person who is earning 110 thousand dollars
without having any debt can
borrow 11 thousand dollars and thus spend
121 thousand dollars although in reality he only
earned 110 thousand
his expenses are the income of another and
following the transactions we can
begin to see how this  process follows
a self-reinforcing pattern
but let's remember borrowing creates
cycles and if the cycle goes up at some
point it must come down
this leads to the short-term debt cycle
when economic activity increases
we see an expansion the first phase of the
cycle  short-term debts spending
continues to grow and prices begin
to rise this happens because the greatest
expense is at  fueled by credit that
can be created instantly out of
thin air when spending and income
rise faster than the production of
goods prices go
up rising prices is called inflation
the central bank doesn't want too much
inflation because it causes
problems seeing that prices  the bank
goes up interest rates go up with
higher interest rates fewer people can
afford to borrow and the cost of
existing debt goes up for example
our monthly credit card payments go up
as people
borrow less and have to pay more  because of
their debts they have less money
available to spend and spending
slows down and since one person's spending is
another person's
income income goes down and so on
when people spend less prices
go down and that is called deflation
economic activity decreases and  we have
a regression if the recession becomes
too severe and inflation is no longer
a problem the bank  o central will
lower interest rates so that everything goes back up again
with low interest rates
debt repayments are reduced
borrow more and spend more and we see
another expansion as we see the economy
works as a magnitude in the
debt cycle  in the short term spending is
restricted only by the willingness of
lenders and borrowers to give and
receive credit when credit is
easily obtained there is
economic expansion when it is not easily obtained
there is a recession and attention
this cycle is controlled in the first place
by the bank  central the
short-term debt cycle usually lasts 5 to 8 years
and repeats itself over and over again for
decades but you will notice that the
bottom and the top of each cycle
end with more growth
than before and more debt because
because people  pushes him is more inclined
to take loans and spend than to pay
debts it
is human nature
that is why in the long run debts
grow faster than i  income
creating the cycle of long-term debt even
though people are more indebted
lenders are more easily
credited because everyone thinks that
things are going very well if people think
only about recent events
and what happened
recently income  asset values ​​went
up stock market goes up red it
's a boom it's a good idea to buy merchandise
services and financial assets with
borrowed money when people do a
lot of that we call it a bubble
so even though debts have been
growing incomes have grown almost
as much
debt to income ratio I
'll call it the debt burden as long as
incomes continue to rise the
debt burden remains manageable
simultaneously asset values
skyrocket people take out
huge loans to buy
investment assets and make  that its
price rises even more people feel
rich of m  hen even with a lot of
accumulated debt rising incomes and
assets help
borrowers stay
creditworthy for a long time obviously
it can't go on forever
and it doesn't happen over decades
the debt burden builds slowly and creates
growing refunds
when these refunds start to
grow faster than income they
force people to cut their spending
and because one person's spending is another person
's income income starts
to go down which makes people
less credit worthy and  reduces
borrowings payments to pay off
debts continue to rise
causing spending to fall further and the cycle to
reverse
this is the peak of long-
term debt debt burdens have
become too great
in the us europe and much of the world  world
this happened in 2008 it
happened for the same reason as in japan
in 1989 and in the us in 1929 the economy is
now beginning to deleverage
in  In this phase, people reduce spending,
income falls, credit disappears,
assets fall, banks suffer,
stock markets collapse, social tensions
increase and everything begins to
feed back in the opposite direction
as incomes fall and
debt payments rise.  borrowers
are stranded no longer entitled to
credit their credit dries up and they
can no longer borrow enough money
to pay off their
desperate debts borrowers are
forced to sell assets
sales fever floods the market this is where
the stock market crashes the real estate
market  sinks and banks have a hard time
when assets fall in price
collateral values ​​of
borrowers fall this makes
borrowers even less deserving of
credit people feel poor credit
disappears quickly less spending less
income less wealth less credit
fewer loans taken and
so on it is a vicious circle
it resembles a recession but the
difference here is that interest rates cannot be
lowered to save
the situation in a recession lowering the
rate stimulates borrowing
but in deleveraging lowering
rates does not work because interest rates
already  they're low and they hit 0% soon so
the stimulus is over interest rates
in the us hit 0% during
the deleveraging of the
1930s and again in 2008 the difference
between a recession and a
deleveraging is that in this the
burden  of debt on borrowers
grew too large and could not be relieved by
lowering interest rates
lenders understand that
such excessive debts cannot be
fully repaid borrowers lost their
ability to pay and their collateral
lost value they feel paralyzed
by debt and that's it  they don't want more the
lenders stop lending the
borrowers stop borrowing let's
think of the economy as unworthy of
credit as  a person
what to do then with
deleveraging
the problem is that
debt loads are very high and must come down there are
four ways this can happen
1 people companies and governments cut
their spending 2 debts are reduced
through moratoriums and restructuring 3 the
wealth is redistributed from the
haves to the have-nots 4 the
central bank prints new money
these four ways occurred in every
deleveraging in modern history it
is customary to cut spending first
as we saw people companies banks and
even government tighten their belts and
cut back  spending to be able to pay off their
debts this is often called
austerity when borrowers
stop taking on new debts and start
paying off old debts the debt burden can be expected
to come down
but the opposite is true how
spending and spending is cut  one person is another person's
income this makes
income fall faster than it is
known  Debts go up and so the
debt burden actually gets worse
as we saw this spending cut is
deflationary and painful businesses
are forced to cut costs which
means fewer jobs and higher unemployment
this leads to the next stage debts need to
be reduced many don't  can
repay their loans and the debts of the
borrower are the asset of the lender
when the borrowers do not pay the
bank the people fear that the bank will not be
able to pay them theirs and run to withdraw
their money from the bank
the banks are restricted and the
people the companies and  the banks are defaulting on
their debts this is a serious economic downturn it
is a depression
much of a depression is
discovering that what we thought was
our wealth is not there
let's go back to the bar
when we buy a beer account
we promised to pay the bar owner
our promise became  an
asset of the barman if we do not fulfill the
promise we do not pay him and we go into
moratorium on our bar
ent account  once this asset that it had is in fact
worth nothing in essence it has disappeared
many lenders do not want to see their
assets disappear and agree to
restructure the debt this means
that the lenders will receive a
smaller reimbursement or that they will collect over a
longer period or with less interest than
agreed  Initially,
in this way, a contract is breached
despite the fact that the debt is reduced, the
lenders thus prefer a little
something before the total of nothing, despite the
fact that the debt disappears, its
restructuring makes the
income and asset values ​​disappear
faster with  which the debt burden
continues to get worse
how to cut spending reducing debt
is also painful and deflationary
all this affects the central government
because lower income and less employment
means the government collects less
taxes at the same time it needs to
increase its spending because of the increase in
unemployed
many of the unemployed have
inadequate savings and need financial support
government budget
plus governments create
incentive plans and increase their spending to
compensate for the downturn in the economy
government budget deficits
only grow during a
deleveraging because they spend more than
they take in taxes that's what
's happening when we hear about the
deficit in  the news to
finance deficits governments
must raise taxes or borrow money
but with falling incomes and
so many unemployed who will get the money
from the rich since governments
need more money and wealth is
highly concentrated in the hands of a  small
percentage of people it is natural
for governments to tax the
wealthy more which facilitates a
redistribution of wealth in the
economy from the haves to the
have-nots the have-nots and sufferers
begin to resent
the rich who  have those who have
suffering from the weak economy the prices
of the ac
If the depression
continues, the social order may be altered,
not only will internal tensions rise
within the countries, but also between
countries, especially between debtors and
creditors, this situation may lead  to
a political change that can sometimes be
extreme
in the 1930s that this led
hittner to power to war in europe
and depression in the us the pressure
to do something to end the
depression is increasing remember what the
most thought money was
actually credit so when credit
disappears people don't have enough
money people are desperate for
money remember who can print it
the central bank
having already lowered its
interest rates to almost zero is forced to
print
money unlike the  spending
cuts debt reduction and
wealth redistribution
money printing is inflationary  and stimulating
inevitably the central bank prints
new money out of thin air which it uses to
buy financial assets and government bonds it
happened in the us during the great
depression and again in 2008 when its
central bank the federal reserve
printed over 2
trillion dollars
and  other central banks in the world that
could also print a lot of money
buying financial assets with this
money helps to raise asset prices
making people more creditworthy
but this only helps those who have
financial
assets because the central bank can  print
money but can only buy financial assets
the central government for its part can
buy goods and services and pass
money to people but cannot print
money so to stimulate the
economy the two must cooperate by
buying government bonds the
central bank essentially lends  money to the
government by allowing it to run a
deficit and increase spending and  n goods and
services through their
unemployment insurance and incentive programs this
increases people's income
as well as government debt
however will reduce the
overall debt burden on the economy
this is a time of great risk for
policymakers  they must
balance the four ways in which
the debt burden is reduced
the deflationary ways must
balance the inflationary ones to
maintain stability
if they are balanced correctly
a beautiful deleveraging can take place
and that is that a deleveraging can be
ugly or beautiful
as it can be beautiful
although  a deleveraging is a
difficult situation optimally managing
a difficult situation is a beautiful thing
much more beautiful than the
unbalanced, debt-fueled excesses
of the leverage phase
in a beautiful deleveraging
debts decline relative to
income real economic growth
is positive and inflation  it's not a
problem you get  e with the
right balance the right balance calls for
some mix of spending
cuts debt reduction
wealth transfer and money printing to
maintain economic and social stability
people ask if
money printing will cause inflation
falling credit is not compensated  let's remember spending
is what matters that a dollar of spending
paid for with money affects prices
just like a dollar of spending paid for with
credit by
printing money if the central bank
can compensate for the disappearance of
credit with an increase in the amount of
money to exchange  In this situation, the
central bank needs not only to
encourage income growth, but also
to make the growth rate of
income exceed the interest rate on
the accumulated debt, what do I mean by
that? Essentially, income must
grow faster than debt, for
example.  Suppose a
deleveraging country has a
debt to income ratio of 100%
est.  or it means that your total debt is
equal to the income of the entire country in
a year
now let's think about the interest rate
on that debt let's say 2% if the
debt grows at 2% for that
interest rate and the income grows only at  1% will
never reduce the debt burden
enough money needs to be printed
so that the rate of
income growth exceeds the interest rate
however printing money is easy to abuse
because it is so easy and because
people prefer it to  the alternatives
the key is to avoid printing too much
money and causing
unacceptably high inflation like germany did
in the deleveraging of the
1920s if policy makers get the
balance right deleveraging
is not as dramatic growth is
slow but debt loads go down
this is beautiful deleveraging with
rising incomes borrowers
start to look more
credit worthy and when this happens
lenders go back to
lending debt burdens are finally starting to come down
as borrowing power people can
spend more the economy is now starting to
grow back towards the
reflation phase of the long-term debt cycle
although deleveraging can be
horrible if mishandled when
handled properly will fix the
problem it
takes about ten years or more for
loads to come down and economic activity to
return to normal and hence the
expression of each loss in conclusion
of course the economy is a bit more
complex than this template
suggests
but superimposing the
short-term debt cycle with the long-term debt cycle
and both on top
of the productivity growth line
to see where we've been, where
we are, and where we're likely to
go, in short, there are three rules of
thumb that I'd like to see
The first thing that will remain from this talk is that
the debt does not grow faster than the
income because the burdens of the
debt  they will end up crushing us the second
that revenues do not grow faster
than productivity because that will make us
uncompetitive and the third do everything
possible to increase productivity
because in the long term that is what matters most
are simple advice for everyone
including those responsible for
Surprisingly most people
and also
policy makers do not pay enough attention
to this and this template has worked for
me and I hope it will work for
yours thank you very much